hey guys pete here it's time to discuss
episode 8 of better call saul's final
season
it was another doozy after the
mid-season break and i've invited some
friends here to talk about it we we do
have a first time guest and
two of these people actually saw this um
early at the tribeca film festival and
um i thought that would be you know they
had a little extra time to process
things and i thought they might have
some interesting insights as a result
and i'm definitely curious to hear what
they have to say
i have a lot of thought about i have a
lot of thought of thoughts about this
episode but before we jump in i do want
to
hear what my guests are thinking about
it overall their impression of the
episode
and also give them a chance to introduce
themselves
and then we'll come back around to me
and i'll you know add what i think and
then we'll go through the entire episode
and answer your questions so
start off with gil why don't you uh
introduce yourself and you you are one
of the people who saw it at tribeca so
how do you feel about this episode now
that you've had some time to let it
settle in awesome thanks pete for having
me on and uh quick introduction i'm gil
this is my brother adam
so if you're familiar with saulcast
we're the two i'd say primary voices of
saul cast some of our emojis that's
right some of our other brothers are
kind of a rotating cast of characters on
the show
um so
overall i thought it was another great
episode of better call saul
i think anyone who was unhappy with the
pacing of episodes four through six
probably were pretty happy with the
pacing of episode seven and i think that
likely continued into episode eight i
remember watching it at tribeca and
first off it was just awesome to watch
this in a theater with an audience there
were a few
laugh out loud moments which is odd to
say in such a dark episode
uh and on top of that
it was very intense especially the first
you know 10 to 15 minutes
when one of our you know our favorite
character our favorite non-breaking bad
character whose fate is unknown when kim
is in the crosshairs again it's a very
uncomfortable and intense situation i
remember in the theater thinking that
once that sort of got resolved and she
was safe and it became more about gus
versus lalo to me it was a different
feeling because i felt inevitability
there especially people like us who
spend 10 hours a week analyzing and
talking about the show it's impossible
to forget gus's gun down in the lab and
we of course know it was almost funny to
hear the line where gus says you can't
kill me and then i fill in the blank
because i'm in breaking bad
we know lalo is not walking out of there
it's very unlikely lala's gonna walk out
of the lab at that point so i no longer
felt tension
i did feel uncomfortable because we're
in this dark
underground place we're dealing with
life and death
uh so is a different sort of intensity
and then coming out of that i felt sort
of i felt sad especially for howard and
for how that's going to affect jimmy and
kim i mean the tragedy of that opening
scene at the beach
and i felt excitement because we've now
closed the chapter on two of the main
conflicts of season six howard and lalo
what's going to happen with these two
characters and they're both literally
buried in the same grave something i
don't think any of us saw coming
and now it feels like we're in the end
game
it's a total open book to me what
happens in the next five episodes you
know we're rapidly approaching breaking
bad
gene
and uh i'm uncomfortable i'm scared and
i'm excited
yeah you know i i i can echo a lot of
the things that you're saying there and
um i'll give everyone else a chance to
to introduce themselves but yeah i think
that that was my biggest takeaway was
that
the inevitability of it
you know it it it diminished my
experience the first watch but
at the same time i really like the way
they handled it you know i and so we'll
we'll get into that when we get into the
recap but i i just wanted to point out
that i had that sort of a really similar
reaction to the to the episode overall
adam you wanna you wanna add something
there
yeah um i mean gil covered a lot of this
really well which is the just the
the sheer awesomeness of everything that
occurred in the plot and so i echo all
of that and i just want to
to build on it and say the fact that
there's still five episodes left and
we've already resolved so many questions
so many characters have met their
fates uh
it makes me feel like the next five
episodes it's almost like a clean slate
that they're starting with and it's kind
of a new form of suspense what's gonna
happen with gene
uh how do we fit everything in with the
breaking bad timeline so so that's one
side of things and the other thing i
wanna
to
say is just
the
actual
uh
construction of the episode like what it
was made up of in terms of
cinematography music acting this was
some of the highest quality television
we've ever seen
uh
and i just think it needs to be praised
even just for something as
as as in a sense surface level as that
totally removed from the plot and
everything like that it was so carefully
cracked crafted it was it was incredible
yeah it's fantastic
and before we move on i just want to
big ralph wanted to say yo to your your
one take bros
good to see you big ralph
so i just wanted to get that out of the
way and
we have uh we have a new guest like i
said um there were a lot of requests
that we
involved courtney
in the last couple of live streams we
had and um
we got to know each other a little bit
in the mid-season break and had some
conversation so i thought we'd have her
on why don't you introduce yourself tell
us about your channel
and what you thought about this episode
which you also saw
in the movie theater in new york city
yes i did hi everyone my name is
courtney for those of you that don't
know me my channel is courtney's reviews
i am the new kid on the block so thank
you very much um pete for having me on
and
i love talking about this show so i only
um have talked about better call saul
but i hope to do breakdowns of some
other things once the series ends so
yeah uh see very similar to how gill
felt um seeing it on the big screen was
quite an experience and people kept
asking me well what did you think what
were your impressions
and i was hesitant to answer that
because my experience was so colored by
the thrill of being there but having
seen it again last night at home on my
couch it was every bit as good and when
you have vince gilligan directing and
you have gordon smith writing you know
it's going to be an awesome episode and
it delivered and for me it was very much
a payoff episode it is a plot resolution
episode much like episode 7 where we see
the resolution to the jimmy and kim
scheme i think this one was obviously
the resolution to the lalo story line so
i have a lot more thoughts but i'm going
to hand it back to you pete so we can
get more into the nitty gritty and yeah
hi everyone in the in the chat saying hi
to me
yeah i i thought that like i talked to
we talked a little bit off-screen and um
yeah the inevitability of it is
it it's always a problem in a prequel
because like we you know we we had this
twice now we we know in nacho whenever
you know nachos taken out to the desert
we know what happens to everyone else
besides him so it's pretty obviously
it's going to die um he's going to die
and it was the same with lalo you know
i've been saying this since
you know a few weeks now that there was
no way he was getting out alive
how can they make it really matter how
can they make it really a fantastic
thing and you know my when i
what i like about this is that it
once you get past that once you get past
the inevitability of of of what's going
on
it's really impressive and adam you
talked about this a little bit it's
really impressive just the way
they used every tool in the box you know
to make this
memorable and exciting despite it the
fact that we know what's going to happen
you know what i mean and and it there's
not many
shows i can think of that really go into
that territory
of where you know it's like hey we know
you're gonna
we know that you know this is gonna
happen we're not even gonna try to you
know trick you about it we're gonna show
you what what you know what's gonna
happen but we're going to make it we're
going to do that in a way that you're
going to still
you know be completely
excited and it's it's awesome you know i
mean it it turned out really well
and we'll get into the recap here
the only other thing i wanted to say
though is that because of the
i think that it and i talked to courtney
about this too but i think that the fact
that they had the six-week break kind of
gave us a little bit too much time to
uh mourn howard's death you know what i
mean like it it was like
when you watched this episode i was
already kind of over the fact that he
died it wasn't still fresh in my mind he
almost was like furniture there
in in the living room you know
the shock had worn off
[Laughter]
yeah did any of you guys pick up on that
of it you thought it might have been
more effective if we saw it back to back
and like it's kind of hard for you guys
who saw it early to see what about you
adam did you think that that would have
been more effective if we saw it one
week right after the other you know um
would it be a bit more effective that's
hard to say i think it's kind of a
personal thing for me
uh
every and every time i thought about the
the last episode before the break
the death kind of hit me again like
every time i thought about it i would
kind of have a renewed sense of
of like pseudo grief you know as much
creep as you can have for a fictional
character uh so i'd say in my case
personally i don't think it mattered too
much that there was a break but i
totally see where you're coming from and
and i i could see that happening for
plenty of people where you kind of have
had enough time to pass that it loses
the impact when you finally return to
the storyline
yeah and and i mean to be fair and we'll
we'll get to this but you know it all
rushed right back in whenever they threw
them into the into the the grave
together you know well and even on that
note like the to the point of how well
crafted the episode was they did such a
good job on his corpse
and it would be hard to see that and not
not have the feelings rushed back the
way you're describing
yeah and i was listening to the insider
podcast and they were talking about i
was wondering i was like did they throw
real people in there and you know is
that really patrick fabian that they
tossed inside the hole and it's actually
stuntman you know they don't use like
dummies or whatever
but they you know they are acting as
they're they're laying there you know
and it's pretty it's pretty fascinating
that he he did a whole episode where he
just played dead
all right so we got one super chat here
and then we'll jump into to the recap of
the story it's big ralph again thank you
for the five dollars
he says with an exclamation point no
clean slate
kim will fall apart on bad choice road
ptsd and murder investigation will do
her in one way or another
and yeah um i understand the sentiment
here ralph we'll be definitely getting
into this when we you know when we get
to that part of the aftermath of of her
going to gus's house and um well we'll
definitely address this
i i'd say the the main thing
to respond to what you're saying here is
that the main thing that jumped out to
me was the way that that what's going on
with her is a mirror of what happened to
jimmy in you know after chuck's death
and after his trip to the desert this
episode was kim's trip to the desert you
know it was her it was her not
necessarily her bad choice road but her
um
what was the 508 title bag man yeah
so you know this this is what i that's
that was my takeaway you know
the instant takeaway about it was man
this was her bat you know her bag man
where she she went through the desert
and she's going to come out a different
person just like jimmy did
all right so
the episode did pick up exactly where
the last one left off and
we finally find out what lala's plan for
being there is and it you know it's
initially to me i was like wait a minute
this is this is a little bit half cocked
you know what i mean like he's gonna
send these two people that are
absolutely freaked out
to do this a really important job you
know after he's been so meticulous about
the whole thing and you know it turns
out that that isn't the case that this
is all essentially a diversion so that
he can get into the super lab
but i thought you know what
what was i i think for me the big point
of this like the the big
thing that happened in this exchange was
that we see jimmy make this decision to
send kim in his place and initially you
know you look at that and you say wait
what is happening here is he losing his
mind is he being
you know
is he cowering at this challenge you
know is he really like trying to throw
kim out there and you know it becomes
really clear throughout the episode that
that's not what he's doing
that he's um
you know he's just looking at his
options and they all suck
and at least if he sends kim out there
then she has a chance she could just run
away he'd be fine with it
if you know whoever stays in the
apartment is toast you know i mean like
we've been talking about this uh i've
talked with all of you individually
about this on the way up it's like
there's no
there's no scenario that makes sense for
him to leave these two people alive
after they saw what happened so he has
they have to be valuable to him
and he and he kind of puts a clock on
that
when he tells them that they have to be
back in an hour like there's no way i
mean we know he leaves but in in jimmy's
from jimmy's perspective there's no way
that he sits there and says okay well if
we do this right
he's going to let us go at the end right
i mean is everybody on the same page
absolutely completely agree there was no
way that he was going to leave kim in
that apartment with the man that just
shot howard in the head you know there's
just no way and i think it was it was
clear to me anyway upon verse viewing at
tribeca what he was doing trying to get
her out of the apartment and i think her
hesitation and saying no no no it's
because she knew what he was doing and
she was afraid that whoever stayed would
die so i thought that was very clear and
of course neither of them knew what
lalo's real objective was he just shot
howard in the head you know so they're
gonna take him at his word if he says
you have an hour to get this done i
think they're going to listen to what he
has to say so yeah completely agree that
that was the goal was to get kim out
yeah it was funny um
you know courtney you'll remember at
tribeca i think the theater burst out
last yes we did
and i i think i was one of those people
but more because i knew that the line
could be read as jimmy's a coward and
he's like uh send her instead
but i think i knew and it becomes very
clear as the episode goes on yeah
it was an act of love for kim sure
he's sacrificing himself yeah bob talked
about that after he's like i'm trying to
be a nice guy and everyone's like what
an a-hole he's trying to send her out
yeah i was just going to say that i was
just going to mention in the q a
afterwards that uh bob
you know it was called us out for
laughing at that that moment he's like
we were trying to be romantic it's a
sweet sad scene where we think we're
gonna die and you guys were laughing
there were a few laugh out loud moments
though that you know again like thinking
of the theater experience i don't know
about you guys if you react
differently in a theater like if you
laugh at moments you wouldn't
necessarily laugh at if you're watching
at home i think that was a large part of
it yeah it's definitely more heightened
for sure yeah for sure
yeah when i go to concerts i you know
i'll shout and and sing along and do all
kinds of things that i don't do when i'm
listening to the same music at home so
i mean you don't normally uh mosh in
your living room
i don't sit around and light my lighter
and sit there and uh whatever is is
popular and to do a concert a lighter
now it's the light on your cell phone
right yeah now it's the cell phone huh
i'm showing my age there
we have we have a couple of um
a couple of super chats here so let's
get through these but i i will come back
to what you guys were saying there about
about the kim thing because i think
there's a lot more to get into there
tony corant thank you for the 499. he
says anybody else not thrilled with the
way lalo went out
i guess it was supposed to mean that he
got too cocky but i think it was mostly
luck for gus um
this is another thing that we'll talk
about in more detail later
right now i'll just say that
i thought that
they i thought that they set up a pretty
good
um
i thought it played out in a pretty
satisfying way in that if you really
think about what they're saying to each
other and how they're jockeying for
you know just sort of to kind of get
that next shot in and
i think most of it actually makes sense
when you really look at it it's a little
bit hard because you know you don't want
the character to die and and he has been
nearly super human in a lot of
situations
but i don't think he does anything that
that that is uh
is surprising there he really does need
to have uh this like irrefree like he
this is like a huge earner for the the
cartel you know what i mean like
donald audio doesn't care about their
personal beef what he cares about is
money and gus makes a ton of that so he
has to have something that he can take
back to him that is bulletproof and i
think that that's mostly what we saw him
do there although he did get a little
bit caught up in in the personalities
because
you know they have a a pretty good
rivalry going on there do either any of
you guys want to add anything extra to
that now or do you want to wait until we
come back around to it
i would just comment that i think lalo's
downfall was his hubris so i think in
this whole universe every character has
sort of their achilles heel with walt it
was his ego his pride wanting to be the
big man um with gus his downfall was
because he had this thirst for revenge
against the salamancas he wanted to get
hector and i think with uh lalo it was
hubris it was this over confidence and
this this over pride to um the the
gentleman that just sent in the super
chat was a tony was that his name was
was i think hinting at um it was it was
a sense of of wanting to be able to
prove something what does it really
matter
um that he proved that that that gus had
this lab it was really more i think like
an excuse for him to be able to kill him
and i think we'll talk about this more
later they did mention this on the
insider podcast as well why he actually
records because it lets him give his
little spiel where he's talking directly
to donald audio and everything but i
think it was just an excuse to get rid
of gus because they hate him
that was the way i read it
no that is true like i said it there is
a an actual
uh you know personal rivalry it's become
personal and gus did try to kill him at
the end of last season yeah and
and like he brought up in this episode
you know he killed people that mattered
to him uh innocent people for that
matter so
yeah i i i
i i don't know i i don't know what else
they could have done that that could
have really
been a better send off for him other
than staying true to the character that
he was and you know going down uh
he pretty much got everything he wanted
it just that it was followed up with him
getting killed right afterwards right
yeah i was bumped to see him go because
what a great villain right like such a
fun villain but there was no way that
both he and gus could exist in this
world there's only room for one top dog
at any given time if this this universe
has taught us anything so there's just
there was no way he could he could get
out of it
all right um gg gj nelson thank you for
the 9.99 there's no question there but
we do appreciate it
is that avatar is a it's a nice reminder
that because i'm in the market for new
classes so
it's useful it's useful too
it has a purpose uh devonte marica
muric
20 thank you very much that's very
generous
season six said gus finds love uh peter
gould said that guess was all about
using others to save his own skin
till he saw nacho the father mike's all
selfless ex
he knew lolo would have killed mike so
he didn't tell him about the lab it
could have
i i so i what i what i'm interpreting
this is is that you think that he didn't
tell mike
what was going on because he wanted to
protect mike um that wasn't my that
wasn't my take about it uh
i did see
an interview with gordon smith and they
they he was talking a little bit about
his motivation and having that
conversation um you know like talking to
eladio and we'll get into that later
but i i he did get that from nacho but
it was i think he used it more of a as a
um
as a stalling technique you know like he
want he realized that this was a way
that he could uh
hold hold uh lala's attention for a few
minutes
while he got ready to spring his plan
into action
um did any of you guys pick up on this
what this uh commenter saying here did
you think that there was a chance gil
that maybe
he knew that he did this because he
wanted to protect mike
or am i reading this wrong
uh no i think you're reading the comment
correctly and like you that's not how i
read the situation
um i mean it's the first time i'm
hearing the idea so i'd have to think
about it and see how it fits
but that it could have line to me was
said by gus in such a stabbing way of
mike you really could have screwed this
up i didn't hear in that
you know
sorrow like it could have ended with you
dying and i did this for your protection
so i'll say that on first read this
doesn't ring true to me um but it's an
interesting idea i have to think about
yeah i i think um one of the things that
that i thought about that as far as like
you know what was
why didn't he tell him i think part of
that isn't so much about like the why
but
it kind of goes to like the fact that
lalo actually did i mean mike is he's
like mike is his own kind of super
powered you know kind of guy and he did
get one upped by lalo all the way across
the board here
you know none of what he tried to do to
protect gus actually worked
so i wonder if there is wasn't certain
of a certain point where gus said you
know what i'm going to handle this
myself because i want it done right
almost
i have a different
i have a different take on this scene so
um
i i'm a little unclear if you mean like
why he didn't like tell
mike when he hid the gun in the
excavator or why he didn't tell
that tell him that he was going to the
lab when he went to the lab in the most
recent episode because i don't think he
realized what
lala was up to until he was talking to
kim on the phone and kim is telling me
yeah that's that's true for sure yeah
and then kim tells him that originally
it was supposed to be jimmy that was
sent but then he was trying to save her
so she went instead and um she explains
that jimmy talked lalo out of sending
jimmy and he was like huh and um i think
a bunch of people in the theater laughed
when they heard that because they were
like like like gus was impressed with
jimmy's powers of persuasion i don't
think that's what it was i think that
was a look of epiphany that was
realization he realized that it was just
a ploy to flush him out and be able to
get into the laundry so i think it was
like he was thinking on his feet and
went to the laundry at that moment there
wasn't really time to do anything else
yeah i kind of i kind of agree because i
think they definitely set that up for
him you know the with the with him
hearing curly fries or
whatever before you know
spice curls and
and those other kind of little
revelations he's had during the season i
think they totally set that up there for
you know us to see like okay well that's
where the light bulb comes on
and i i i just think that you know as
far as what the the commenter was asking
um
i just thought that it you know it
things were left in a kind of weird
place between gus and mike because of
the situation you know they're not we
can see that they're not really like on
the same page but i don't know if
there's anything more to it yet we'll
have to see if it how it develops from
there um eight
hnic8 thank you for the 499. mike has
now failed so many on so many levels the
past couple of episodes
how will he redeem himself and surpass
tyrus with the threat of lalo now gone
that's a good question and one i'm not
sure that we're going to get an answer
this is this really reminds me of
when we got to the end of the nacho
episode and people were saying what are
we going to find out about this or what
are we going to i mean i kind of feel
like the mic and gus part of the story
is now concluded um
you know like maybe they
will will
will
intersect the stories will intersect in
in a way you know if they serve
what's going on with jimmy and kim but i
don't expect a whole lot more
backstory on these two i feel like
lala was the the conclusion
what do you guys have kind of a question
about this so if we look forward at
breaking bad
uh
how high up do we think mike was
in terms of the henchman hierarchy
you know did he did he ever really climb
that much higher than than this point or
maybe these things actually
lead to him
being less promotable
i kind of have to think back because
it's kind of hard to say how
how much of a right-hand man was he
versus someone a little bit lower
my impression was that he was above
tyrus in in the hierarchy and during
breaking bad
yeah so i understand
i understand a um i understand kind of
where the the poster is coming from you
know
asking about that uh
but it's maybe it's not as clear as i
thought it was when i watched the series
you know what i mean but i i think that
he he's definitely his most important
person at that point
if that's oh sorry go ahead i was just
gonna say i'm not sure that i would
agree that mike has has failed how did
he fail in this most recent episode i
mean apart from like he pulled his guys
off of the apartment right to to put
them on the laundry and on gus
um and then but but
as we were just saying he had no idea
that that gus was going to the laundry
so how could he protect him if i think
that he um demonstrates his usefulness
as a cleaner right and like he's he's
resourceful in that way and like
plotting out like what was going to
happen with howard and and um the car
and all that and having done all this
like intel on kim and jimmy and
collecting all that evidence right i
think he's very useful in problem
solving
to gus in that way
yeah courtney i want to second that
that's
exactly what i was just thinking
is that mike lost a chess match against
lala the way i read yeah
yeah
exactly so basically i think gus is
learning where mike is useful like you
said he's not going to be the person who
formulates a strategy
and outmatches a lalo and realizes oh
lalo is heading to the lab
uh you know like gus had that hunch
earlier and set up the gun there so i
think this is more about gus getting to
know mike
how does he end up uh above tyrus in the
hierarchy i think to your point we see
he is very good at a few specific things
and so gus sets him up for that he can
competently execute
real-life plans but when it comes to
the high scale strategy esp like that's
more difficult for him especially when
he's given incomplete information uh and
that is gus's fault
yeah
there are a few people that can match
lalo and gus and walt right like they're
in a different league
[Music]
yeah
yeah i i i think you i i i i understand
where the the person who asked the
question is coming from but i think you
guys are right i don't think that their
relationship has been damaged or that he
sees mike as a failure i think that they
were up against a really tough oppo
opponent there everybody respects that
was the situation that was happening and
i when i said that you know la la one
upped him i was thinking more on the
personal level of mike you know i mean
being like
feeling like you know he lost the match
or whatever you know what i mean
um mr g thank you for the five dollars
salt introduces walt to gus in breaking
bad right
do you think we'll see august and jimmy
seen or should we just assume that
relationship develops off screen
um
i'll throw this out to the other the
other people here but
my my kind of rule of thumb or like you
know my my my thinking internally on on
what they should show in the breaking
bad timeline
is a lot more about
how how these character like i wanted to
reveal things about jimmy and kim
you know i'm not so worried about
filling in the blanks or or
or
augmenting the breaking bad experience i
think those that will naturally happen
if you're doing things that are you know
like if we're seeing other scenes from
different perspectives
i want it to be for the purpose of
having a better idea of how
jimmy became who he was and how the
ending of the story will play out
and you know what happened to kim and
and why is you know why is she not there
is she gonna you know is there a
possibility for her to come back that's
where i want
the breaking bad stuff to tie in i i
don't really you know it's like it's
sort of like the question of like do we
need to know about gus's backstory you
know in a way
we saw that he can shoot a gun you know
that probably comes from that period of
time in his life you know like his you
know
it fits in
it's just like you know i'm way more
interested in
in the story of jimmy and kim than i am
and as well i mean breaking bad's
already good as it is i don't know that
we need to add
stuff just for the sake of doing it
what do you guys think
i think i'd second everything you just
said pete
um
and if i were to think about a gus and
jimmy scene and could it serve a purpose
for the jimmy character as an important
milestone in his story if you wanted to
have a scene that establishes
jimmy is now saul goodman and he is
firmly entrenched in this world a brief
scene of him meeting gus and them
looking at each other not as equals but
looking at each other as two players in
this in this game
that could be an important moment that
says symbolically he's here now but i
think there's a lot of ways you could
say that it doesn't necessarily have to
be jimmy meeting gus so i guess the
answer is we might see it and if we do i
hope it serves a thematic purpose and
isn't just look these two characters are
meeting how cool is that
yeah i would be surprised if we saw that
because i'm not sure at what point
in breaking bad that uh that saul
actually even becomes aware of gus's
real name when he introduces limits to a
guy who knows a guy who knows a guy
and um at one point
when he's when jesse is gonna skip town
he asks
him to put in a good word with gus for
old time's sake you know so there's not
a real relationship there it's through
these other parties it's through mike
it's through jesse and walt so i would
be surprised i'm more interested in
what's going to happen now with kim now
that she's seen the inside of his house
and heard his voice
what could happen there
yeah we'll come back around to that for
sure
cj graves did you have anything on that
adam i didn't want to cut you off if you
no i i stuck in every pretty much most
of what you guys said
okay cj graves five dollars do you think
although we know it can't happen that
lalo should have logically killed jimmy
instead of leaving him in the apartment
ah i i don't know
um
i hadn't i hadn't thought of that really
you know like i i guess he could have he
could have just killed him as soon as
she went out um
i think he was actually really going to
come back because he did say he was
going to come back and they were going
to talk some some more so i think had he
survived the lab he definitely would
have really come back
um for who knows what else that he he
would have done with them but
he does know jimmy has
information that he hasn't just had the
chance to extract yet so there's some
incentive there and also in general lalo
is kind of such a
he's such an interesting character
because he doesn't even care about tying
up loose ends he just kills when it's
convenient or when he wants to prove a
point um in that situation what is
killing
saul goodman in that scenario really do
for him it almost feels like a coin flip
he could do it he could not
he happened not to
yeah adam that's a great point i don't
think he just kills without like
indiscriminately like he lets margaret
to live he lets the dog live um you know
he only kills when it really serves a
purpose for him i think yeah i think he
has a very low threshold for what counts
as serving that purpose
right
yeah the only thing i can think of of
not killing him is that he he would you
know make kim an enemy
if if she came back into the picture
there's a possibility that if she just
if he just kills jimmy then you know
that could come back to him in that way
but it's pretty you're basically making
another version of gus if you do that
yeah
another person hell bent on revenge
yeah
uh craig otto thank you for the five
dollars for whatever reason this is the
first time i worried about jimmy's goal
yeah i worried about it too
um
no we don't know what the status of it
is it's not something it's not a
character you know we talk about all the
characters who never showed up in
breaking bad and i believe that the
goldfish is in that category
we don't see a goldfish in the in the
scene where where they're kind of
repossessing all the stuff all the
evidence or all the things that value
you know
the season how long do goldfish even
live does anyone know 10 to 15 years
just google this it depends
how good of a tank you store them in
yeah in the wild they can live pretty
long
nice
okay so
uh yeah uh sir torchington
4.99 i love how lalo's death was
literally the only time they have not
subverted our expectations with how it
went down
thus subverting our expectations yeah
yeah i i i think we touched on this a
little bit already um
there is a you know it's kind of a flex
whenever you're going to do you know you
can just say look this is exactly what
you thought's going to happen
but it's still going to blow your mind
you know
the big surprise i think sorry
go ahead i was just going to say for for
me the big surprise was the the hole
with howard in it i think i didn't see
that coming
yeah and it was i just visually uh
really kind of a powerful image
i think and
and i think it left a strong impression
on most viewers
and regarding whether or not they they
did something surprising i would say
yeah especially because we had so much
time to predict uh
during the break this went down exactly
how many people saw it
and i have some experience about that
but in the end the the purpose of
telling this story is not to to surprise
us it's to
show us
in the end this show is about
really it's about saul goodman and it's
about kim wesler um and the events of
this episode are going to be
absolutely crucial and pivotal to the
character development of those people
and that's
i think more important than
than okay we know lalo probably has to
die are we going to surprise people by
the way it's done or just play it out
the way it logically would happen
i think that's i saw somebody in the
chat say they think a six week break
would have worked better after this
episode and i know there were things
behind the scenes that caused it to
happen so they didn't have a choice but
yeah i actually do agree with that just
in terms of the viewing experience
because plan and execution was so
shocking
and i feel like by the time we got to
this episode that shock had kind of worn
off and now we're ready for another
shock but instead this felt like the
inevitable conclusion after that event
and so i think it would have worked
better as almost the epilogue
immediately after that episode and it
wouldn't yeah that's what i was saying
earlier like a two-hour event special
event episode yeah i mean that would
have been amazing
that would have been crazy
quite a run quite a ride
that would have been that would have
been a memorable night of television
right there
especially because it would be coming
off the heels of everyone saying oh
they're they're they're all this setup
you know what's wrong with their pacing
everyone would have had a two-hour
thrill ride
people would have to be walking around
with neck collars on after yeah
[Laughter]
all right data deficient thank you for
the ten dollars love the shot with the
camera on the chair the same chair kim
used to block the door out of fear of
lalo a few episodes back ends up being
the very thing that lalo straps jimmy
down to
yeah i hadn't thought about that i
didn't make that connection i did think
that was cool that they they seemed to
like
mount the camera on the chair whenever
they they moved it they're so good at
doing that yeah
that was that was pretty soon but yeah i
didn't think about the fact that it was
that same chair that she put under the
door handle
let's see here uh robert gay thank you
for the 499 do you think kim will wear
the mask that all is well or will she
disregard mike's orders jimmy becomes
saul
but will count kim turn herself in or
run well i i don't think you know it's
kind of funny because i don't really
know what kim could turn herself in for
technically um at this point
um i don't think that she'll
i mean she can't she couldn't take all
of the
the she couldn't take all of howard's
like the actual murder and things like
she couldn't take responsibility with
that without bringing a lot of other
people in and they would just eliminate
her you know what i mean like
gus or or mike or whoever would have to
just take her out if that was the case
um
yeah i think the big question and we
will come to this because i think this
is the thing that's on everyone's mind
but the big question is how does she
react to her
ptsd
and really you know and and we've
already seen a little bit of it you know
like whenever chuck died jimmy just went
catatonic in a way like he didn't
respond to it at all and we saw that it
had a real effect on her
so you know it it will be different and
and the question isn't so much of like
what but it's just sort of how how could
these two people stay together
and how is that gonna really play out
considering we know that they're not
really together in breaking bad not not
physically together so that's what's
really what you know is interesting me
right now
yeah i feel like the
the fact that she
you know when she was given the freedom
to get in the car and and go uh carry
out the task that lal gave her she chose
to do it uh presumably because she
thought that's this is the way i can
save my husband
but i think in
an equally effective if not more
effective way would be to go immediately
to the police she didn't do that
and she had opportunity she had i mean
they roll up right next to her
so yeah exactly they make the plan they
do a good job of showing showing
concrete uh both ethical and and
practical choices that that she faces
uh which almost always present while
she's in the car which is which is kind
of interesting when you talk about bad
choice wrote it like i'm sure that that
was not lost on the writers at parallel
bad choices on the road yeah exactly so
i don't think we can say for sure but i
think it's a pretty
strong indicator that uh she's not
turning herself in and
uh if anything this might this is these
events might strengthen her in a in a
sense in terms of the the newly
compartmentalized kind of version that
she's becoming well it's interesting the
word compartmentalize because we've
definitely seen jimmy do that like you
mentioned pete after chuck dies and he
learns that he may have played a role in
that when he hears from howard it was
the insurance premiums at that moment
jimmy goes from catatonic to feeding the
goldfish whistling and just having a
grand old time making juice yeah exactly
so he shoves those things down we see
kim compartmentalize as well but for her
it's been less i think avoiding trauma
and more i can do this bad thing over
here and i can come up with a way to
justify it and then go back to following
the rules over here i'm not really sure
how kim will process playing a role in a
tragedy
uh and that gets to the heart of the
person's question we have a we have an
idea how jimmy's going to handle this
but mike says go to work you know
essentially be all smiles in my mind
jimmy does that tomorrow and then keeps
doing it for years as saul goodman i
don't know what he was going to do
that's one of the exciting things that
i'm looking forward to finding out
yeah and real quick jeremy thank you for
the 199. what is left for the mike and
got storyline now um we kind of touched
on this already i mean there's not much
you know
i feel like they kind of wrapped it up
here um but we'll get we'll talk about
it a little bit more when we talk about
lala's ending
yeah i do have some some thoughts on
that so i'm looking forward to getting
that to that part
yeah
i'm looking forward to getting past the
third bullet point as well
harrison thank you for the five dollars
what do you think will happen to the
tape i see three options destroy the
tape to get rid of the evidence keep the
tape like a trophy
show hector um
right
yeah i think they throw as i was gonna
say i think that that they showed mike
throwing the camera and tape into the
grave like individually not just one or
the other but are not just together but
i think if i if i recall correctly
he should he throws both of those things
in there right
yeah yeah i think so yeah
yeah so they're buried at the bottom of
of
they're buried below the super lab to
answer your question
okay
mod mary thank you for the 4.99 nice to
see you i wonder why gus went to the
laundry
he was safe at home lalo would never
figure out the secret entrance down to
the basement
i think he wanted to bring it to an end
i mean that was that's what i was
thinking that he's gonna have to look
over his shoulder for the rest of his
life and he and
he wants to uh take lalo off the board i
mean his his his
his purpose is to eliminate all
salamancas i mean he's made that pretty
clear
and lalo is a particularly pesky one so
that's what i thought does anybody have
any any other ideas on that
well i think there's even some symbolism
i don't think this is directly related
but it feels in the spirit of it which
is
when
we've seen a lot of gus fiddling with
his clothing this season whether it's
his ankle holster adjusting his tie or
putting on a clip-on
this time we see him they make the point
of showing us he takes his tie off right
we don't see that too often i think he's
in a sense he's sick of the constriction
he's like like
that's him saying
i've had enough of this
like i'm taking the tie off it's time to
get my hands dirty and put an end to
this
yeah that's a good point not one that i
had considered i was just caught up on
the fact that he took off the tie and
left the button buttoned up like oh yeah
yeah
i've never seen anyone
pull that move it's like whenever i wore
a tie i would always
do both of those things in concert
because it felt so well
taking the tie off doesn't really change
much
yeah you may have been trying to hide
the vest underneath oh true yeah yeah i
know i agree that there's a lot of
things i'm just saying from like a
reaction standpoint it was just like
why why why leave the button the button
is the bad part
okay yeah so derek roy thank you for the
canadian five dollars chance
chance that additional forensic of the
lab explosion in breaking bad will have
howard lalo dug up
and gene is now really wanted for
questioning in howard's death
well i read an interview where the
interviewer asked gordon smith i think
about this and he said that that didn't
really go through their mind um
i don't know is that a spoiler to say
that because i just did it
so i i don't know i mean it like
that that's that's as far as i thought
about it do you guys have any any
thoughts on this
well uh
i feel well that was some really deep
thick concrete i don't know what the
standard protocol is in in like criminal
investigations
uh
we need to talk i guess if we were
really curious we could talk to someone
who's more familiar with this but
after a fire like that and kind of an
arson along with all the other things
that happened would it be normal to kind
of analyze the concrete below it or
or not i don't know i have a feeling
no but
what do i know yeah and that was my
reaction too but it does
i do wonder if uh that's the last we
hear the last time we hear the name
howard or if that's if there is some
kind of reckoning coming in the gene
timeline could we see jimmy do something
to try and
uh
recover howard's reputation could we see
remember that very heartbreaking phone
call from walt disney mendes that
episode do we see a phone call from
jimmy where he calls someone he says
howard was not a drug user it was not a
suicide
uh i do think about that
that would be part of an interesting
sort of redemption arc i don't know if
the show is
uh setting up for that so it'd be kind
of so far right now i feel unexpected
but i kind of like the idea
i like the idea too and of course jimmy
has no idea he's there but if you know
um since they're doing the investigation
right after the end of season four and
breaking bad so
it's possible that they do unc uncover
unearth those bodies and then maybe
jean sees that on the you know the news
and then that's part of his motivation
to come back and say i know who that is
or you know set the record straight that
would be really really cool if they did
that yeah
you know what would be really kind of
fitting for his character actually is
like
let's say he drops the gene persona he
decides to cooperate and
tell the truth for once and save
howard's reputation and
and also spill the beans on a lot of
other things
uh i could see that as almost being
another phase of jimmy mcgill's life
where he's now
you know like like the guy who
catch me if you can guy who like
eventually kind of told his story like i
could see
a a 70 year old jimmy mcgill after
serving some time doing interviews on
like 60 minutes and and enjoying the
spotlight but also finally kind of
living a more honest life
maybe writing a book about himself right
um
we'll see it'll be like uh game of
thrones where they say they write that
big book no it's called the song of ice
and fire the last episode we'll see uh
jimmy pitching an idea for a series
called better
abby trace uh thank you for the twenty
dollars kim wexler isn't in breaking bad
because obama nominated her to the
supreme court
he's not even a spoiler because it's so
obvious
yeah it's like what else can you say
about the truth do you know what i mean
it's just
it's it's just an unalienable
fact um
sean perkins thank you for the five
dollars what does the walt jesse what
about the walt jesse cameo we know from
breaking bad that walt hasn't seen jesse
since teaching him in class their cameos
would have to be separate right
no wait this is something we've talked
about um
quite a bit
and um i think that the general
consensus uh at least for me and most of
the people that we've talked about on
you know i've talked to on here
is that they're going to show up in the
breaking bad timeline
you know
like
they won't they'll i think that they'll
probably be together
and i think that it will be in relation
to something that tells us you know like
maybe there was something we didn't
understand about what was going on with
with saul at that time that'll give us
more insight to how he might react to
things and
yeah i just think it it sounds like
they're going to be more involved than
just one scene like it's going to be an
actual
you know story but um i think it'll be
in the breaking bad timeline and i think
it will
be in service of the the the jimmy and
possibly the kim story and does anybody
have anything they want to add to that
agree yeah i i think it would be a real
kind of shame if you if you're going to
bring those two characters back
you kind of have to show them together
not in separate cameos otherwise i mean
imagine you think consider the backlash
that happened when uh kind of star wars
was uh revived and
you had an opportunity to have carrie
fisher mark hamill and uh harrison ford
on screen together actually you know
doing the star wars thing and they
didn't do it and i'm not even a huge
star wars fan but even i was
disappointed
um
i don't think they want to make that
mistake
yeah
that i mean it it's just such a it's
such a moment that they can put together
just
when they show up i i don't know i i
agree completely
gregor lee lucas again thank you for the
five dollars how could gus's story be
over he's been going out of his way not
to kill lalo on u.s soil because it
triggers a war he isn't prepared for
needs payoff question mark well no
because lalo did that for him when he
faked his own death the only person that
knows that that lola is still alive is
uh
hector
and he can't really he can't really
reveal that because he can't prove
anything he's he's in a in a wheelchair
in a uh old folks home yeah you know
what i mean
so yeah
part of
you know part of the irony of this all
is that
wallow did such a good job of putting
his plan into action he also screwed
himself in the end because
no one's expecting that no one realizes
that he disappeared you know
all right mendoza's coyote thank you for
the 4.99 lola was limited on time
so he had to leave jimmy there he wanted
jimmy to tell him what really happened
in the desert with mike
i suppose that's true i i just don't
think that was the the most important
thing to him anymore i mean that was
like you know when i made a video about
it and i really thought about it that's
what i thought he was going to do
but it turned out that
he kind of already put that together off
screen that if he if he could get a
diversion going at gus's house that that
would that would free up the people that
were at the laundry so he could get
inside there
anybody want to add to that at all or
agree yeah it was just a diversion
yeah yeah okay 100 aaron thank you for
the five dollars this episode is the
only time we've heard kim called mrs
goodman right that was uh thought that
was cool thanks guys
yeah i thought that was funny too and i
um i'll be interested to hear what you
guys think about that if if that was
like sort of like a dig or if it was you
know he was trying to be cute or is just
like he was calling her that because
you know it's he's she's saul's wife he
actually calls her that excuse me for
the first time in bagman when she goes
to visit him in prison and as he's
putting it together that she's uh his
wife and he's like and you came down
here because you love him and you're
scared yeah
yeah and then at the end he says like
yeah and he
on the desk and says it was nice meeting
you mrs goodman he never knew her real
name
um i don't think i don't think he ever
knew her real name maybe he knew her
name was kim
i do think he finds it funny that she's
married to jimmy and so he gets a kick
out of saying mrs goodman
yeah because he brings it up several
times like how did a guy like you get a
woman like that you know he's like
he's not really like subtle about it at
all i also
kind of have a deeper reading of it i
think
lalo really saw kim he was able to read
her very very well
and um i think that moment when i'm
talking about in bagman when she does go
to visit him she reveals a lot of
herself to him and he he's got her
pegged so when they're debating about
who's going to go to gus's house in this
episode remember in lalo's head he
really wants someone to actually go to
the house right because that's the whole
point is to raise the alarm for gus and
he was sure that she was actually going
to go through with it maybe more so than
anyone else would have would have known
he knew she would actually do it for the
same reason that she didn't go to the
police when she was scared about
generally like she had the hutzpah to
actually go down there and talk to him
and then speak truth to power to him
when she dresses him down you know in
bad choice road so i think he was he was
definitely impressed with her and he
actually saw her maybe perhaps as like
the brains behind the operation so the
mrs goodman and the whole fashioning of
the saul goodman persona is i think a
fun little play and a fun little nod to
that it's really kim driving a lot of
that creation at least that's my reading
yeah of it
yeah and you know i saw i saw a comment
um
where someone was saying that lalu knew
that that kim would be that they would
send kim
and and i hadn't really thought that he
would have thought of it that that far
through but what you're saying there
courtney does
ring true he definitely did recognize
all of those things you know he's good
at reading people and um you know she
laid a lot out she had to be vulnerable
in that situation because of
you know the real threat to to jimmy's
life and so yeah he could definitely put
those two things together there
yeah
um just a lot of this conversation is
making me think of a
just a really interesting topic that i
think
a lot of credit to the writers of the
show which is the the way they play with
people's names and their identities
um and the way different people refer to
others by different uh aliases you have
walter white mr white heisenberg
uh you have lalo or he goes by uh you
know jorge de guzman right uh which
which also guzman means good man and you
have saul goodman you have slip and
jimmy you have kim you have gizelle uh
victor
it goes on and on and you can keep going
and
and a lot of these names have extra
meaning to them and there's a lot of
interesting things to read into
which people will use which names to
refer to other people
um and i think that's just like a topic
with endless step to it uh maybe a
future video essay or something right
there yeah first show that's all about
identity and people changing and i think
on this show maybe even more than
breaking bad people putting on different
faces
it i think definitely falls into that
ballpark like i've never seen a show
where characters have so many different
aliases yeah it's a good point
yeah and i really like they had a little
teaser that didn't really show anything
um that came out you know that where
they showed um
uh jimmy in the salt timeline again
recently
and i really liked how i didn't do a
video about that one but i really liked
how they had
it opened up with like interior and
exterior shots of of the buildings you
know like his his you know we saw his
his his office from the outside first
and then you saw the inside and then you
saw los pollos from the outside and the
inside and i really like that little
play there about you know they they do
they they really
the idea of like who you are and how you
present yourself and and who you become
in the situation and and
you know there's so much of that that
idea of masks and
you know
who who they who like identity basically
you know and and
these right now they're hitting up so
much trauma that like they're they don't
really even know who they are at points
which is is a lot of fun to to try to
sort through what's going on with them
lots of coins thank you for the 4.99 not
sure if this has been brought up yet but
one of the writers said that gus got the
idea to monologue from nachos monologue
before his death yeah and um
i mentioned that earlier and
we'll we'll talk about it again when we
get there but yeah i saw that and
it like i said i thought it made a lot
of sense you know that
he's looking you know he's he he needs
something and he saw that play out just
not that long ago in you know in
uh in the timeline of things
so i thought that was a nice little nod
to him um
thinking on his feet
almeida's army thank you for the 4.99
pound
great panel
like the avengers of bcs youtube
assembling
i still want a flashback scene of all
the salamancas together cousins tuko
hector and lalo i mean that would
definitely be uh entertaining to see
that um
they kind of did that in the other
series but lalo didn't exist or he
wasn't a a fleshed out character at the
time it's sort of like that photo that
they show of tuko and the cousins
with a younger hector all the time
it would be cool um i don't know if
there's time but
i wouldn't be upset if they did that
slant uh
the yeah uh
slaint
these aren't these aren't these aren't
letter combinations that are
easily recognizable for me um thank you
for the 13.99 canadian
knowing that lyle isn't in breaking bad
should we be worried for his safety or
will the pressure of opening and closing
tuesday in a row simply be too much for
him to handle um
i think it's funny you know like when i
was watching this episode i was like
oh it's lyle you know like i was totally
um into it and i thought it was just
really a nice little palette cleansing
scene in between you know what happened
in the two parts of the episode kind of
thing
and i was just like it's one of those
things where you're like oh you know eli
he's such a cool character i really
enjoy him and you don't realize it but
like then i go and i look at the
comments and they're all about life
he's such a fan favorite you know it's
hilarious and you know there are you
know
actions have consequences and and people
like lyle are caught up in it too
there's working you know having to work
those two long shifts you know
it's pretty rough
yeah fun little um
something that happened at tribeca is
when that scene came on like the
audience erupted in laughter i think
that was the hardest we laughed was when
lyle is singing um los boyos hermanos to
the la cucaracha song
which i think is also significant that
he's like
yeah it's like
so yeah i didn't even think about it oh
i didn't think about that i doubt it's a
real song like that's really their
jingle i mean but maybe so i just think
it's interesting the the cockroach again
if it means anything yeah that i mean
that's come up a lot in our
conversations about this season you know
uh where la la just for those who like
courtney i think that's a great
connection and for those who are
uh needed their memory jog that's when
uh kim is worried about
uh saul and she's confronting lalo in
the prison and lana was like oh he'll be
fine he's like who karate always gets
away yeah
roger rubio thank you for the five
dollars just wanted to say thank you for
all the great breakdowns you all provide
to us yeah the thanks for thanks for
that and thanks for watching we wouldn't
probably be making them if you weren't
so
thanks a lot for that um
10 ohm or 10 ornament omen yes six
dollars thank you thoughts on how saul
looked when he found out mike knew about
the plan against howard
he looked at a he looked at kim a few
times like wtf um
i thought this was interesting too
because he
that should have surprised jimmy i i i
don't know if i picked up anything in
his reaction but
i do wonder if that's planting a seed
you know for for the future um
because yeah you know he didn't know she
never told him that they were following
them
really there's no reason for mike to
know all of what they're doing like
nobody like part of what he said to her
on the bed at that one point is nobody
knows what we're doing except for us
that was part of the foundation of why
their plan is going to work and then he
does just sort of find out
that mike knows
and on top of that uh
he doesn't know that he still doesn't
know that kim knew lala was alive
yeah that could be a potential nuclear
bomb the kind of way didn't go up yeah
and some of those looks could have been
that question because it it always takes
me
on initial viewing plan and execution
took me a second to realize just how
it's not when lala shows up it's not
just shock wallows here but he's seeing
a ghost in his mind lala was dead
and
he might look at kim and wonder why are
you not as shocked as i am
you know so there is a pretty big wtf
there and i do think that the seed was
planted that kim knew about this mike
went to her rather than him that seed
was planted and i do think there's a
payoff coming a confrontation or a
discussion between them
yeah i i just don't know that you know
jimmy is going to be
like i can't see him like
i don't know i can't i can see him being
hurt by it but i can't really see it
going much further than that yeah i
agree maybe it'll be like mike being
upset at gus for not telling him about
the laundry like why didn't you mention
it i mean this is more significant
though you know so
yeah yeah but i mean nobody really
thinks that jimmy's going to leave
kim at this point you know what i mean
like over that they they after this
episode you know it really changed
and we haven't really been able to talk
about it yet but it really changed like
uh
everything this episode even though you
know what happened wasn't directly
related to them it it
the the way that their
you know their relationship is is
what it what it depends on
you know it
there's a lot of questions as far as how
how that continues and
not because like you think one or the
other would just be not into it anymore
i mean they're obviously very
they they reestablished
just how intimate they are on this
episode you know
antonio maru
thank you for the 499.
mike did not mess up he's trying to kill
lalo protect gus protect kim and jimmy
in the lab while everyone else is moving
at different speeds
yeah i mean that's what we we that
that's just sort of an agreement with
what we were saying before
um i just said like i thought that on a
personal level he doesn't like to um
you know
he doesn't like that that
he didn't come out on top and and as far
as like you know being able to
anticipate what he was going to do
eight hn ic8 again thank you for the 199
mike unfortunately failed to stop
howard's death
yeah but that's not really his job um to
be fair
i do think it's significant though and
and we were talking a little bit about
this earlier uh not so much for gus i
mean what does gus really care about
howard but i think when he's looking
down at at uh howard and the grave at
the end there is a moment when you hear
the violins or the cello whatever it is
playing and um it's it's almost like
this the sad death knell for howard and
i was telling pete that i was wondering
like what was going through gus um
mike's mind at that time um does he feel
any any amount of responsibility or or
remorse for what happened that that he
wasn't there to stop that from happening
so i think he said
when he says easy with mike's body shows
concern for it uh i think paul hughes in
the chat says mike can't stand when
civilians die and yeah i do think it
cuts deep for him especially in this
case when i mean kim said to him why
weren't you there why weren't you
watching us i certainly think he feels
some guilt that if he were able to
anticipate lalo's actions a civilian
would still be alive yeah the in the
game versus not in the game right
yeah and it's sort of the slow-motion
erosion of that you know i mean because
we know that in breaking bad that he you
know he he pretty much gave up on it in
a way
he might not he might
not like the idea of people getting
caught up but he's he's sort of been um
weathered
in that regard uh compared to when we
first meet him in bcs right and also
just
he's
i think he's reached a point especially
by the time he's in breaking bad where
he doesn't have much of a choice whether
he works for gus anymore or not he's
just in way too deep
and out of self preservation
that sense of justice and in the game
versus out of the game it might be
correct but
all it does is put him and his family in
harm's way
to even dwell on it anymore
yeah
and logically you can see how you would
always kind of end up if you choose that
life you're you're going to end up doing
things that that you don't
you didn't sign up for you're telling
yourself you didn't sign up for but you
know you are actually signing up for
because that's the way it works
swamp crawler ls1 thank you for the five
dollars gus had dozens of hired men so
why didn't he have a shady doctor on his
payroll that was closer to him not three
hours away in another country yeah
fair question um not one that i have an
answer to but it's a fair question
when i see when i think of questions
like this uh the thing i tell myself is
this is still an early look into
like the development of gus's
independent empire
uh
and he's these are growing pins that's
kind of what i tell myself
yeah and he's still learning like the
gus we met in breaking bad
pretty much
he made very few mistakes except when it
came to
playing chess with with walter and and i
mean walter is a
bonafide genius if not more than that um
so that's really him meaning his match
and then the other the only other
mistake you can really think of is just
uh
the
kind of similar to the mistake lala made
which is the hubris at the very end
where
uh you're letting your emotions get the
better of you rather than just finishing
the job uh you know such as when when
gus is kind of uh
taunting hector in his final moments
yeah william feliciner thank you for the
199 nathan m thank you for the 199. well
howard's wife now come to play
with suspicion
i i don't know i mean
i heard people were saying that they
thought that carol burnett might be uh
howard's mother and that might come in
in a um
funeral situation
maybe his wife would come back i mean
they got a a pretty substantial
actor to play that role if if they only
were going to use her for that but i
mean it was also a really effective use
of of the character so i don't know that
i need to see more
of his wife but
um
it's possible
i just it seems like it would be going
it would be wandering
away from things but we do have five
episodes i think at least one
probably two more could happen in the
regular timeline that we're in right now
so i think that's kind of where we'll
we'll figure that out
i have uh an idea about about what's
going to happen with howard beyond this
point because i whenever i'm trying to
speculate what might happen next what
would be the point of showing these
characters like what how would it serve
the plot and at this point like they've
they've really resolved the howard
storyline like they they've now come
with an ex like a a
an explanation for his disappearance his
death so i think if they bring on like a
carol burnett as his mother or if they
show his wife cheryl again it would be
only to have an effect on jimmy or kim
so like maybe like if it's at like a
memorial and they see the morning and
then they feel bad about it that would
be i think the only reason to show how
it's affecting those characters
and i think we're going to see how
they're affected already just by the
aftermath of it so i'm not sure that
they would bring those characters back
[Music]
yeah yeah that's like i said a lot of
this stuff it seems hard i mean i
understand that there's some
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of stuff that they could do out there
you know
at their at their disposal but
um
you know i don't think there's not much
that they have to do you know like i
think that they like you said i think
howard is is pretty pretty wrapped up
you know i mean it's a tragic story
his legacy was something we'll talk
about in a little bit here if we ever
get to it and
i i don't know how you make that better
at this point
you know regarding howard's story and
kind of the
the lie that jim and jimmy and kim had
been selling
uh
they were forced into a situation where
they had to to kind of carry that lie
all the way through to the end and
basically to make it real
in the eyes of everyone and you know
they didn't intend for it to end with a
suicide but if you were to take the the
lie that they were crafting the way they
were framing howard for all these things
if you were to carry it through to the
logical conclusion or the extreme
conclusion uh suicide is kind of where
it ends
similarly the la la la had constructed
about faking his own death so you know
you made the point earlier uh he kind of
did too good of a job because similarly
like that that thing he was kind of
faking
turn into reality and i
you know maybe i'm reading too much into
this show but one thing i've learned is
you kind of never can because the
writers are really smart they thought
about these things too i think
and and one theme behind the show is is
the way you act in the the lies you tell
gain momentum
uh and eventually you lose control of
them and and i think
in a sense these are just two more
examples of that among many that we've
seen in the bcs breakdown first
yeah and ori rob thank you for the the
calif or the canadian five
dollars um i'm not really sure
been looking at this and i'm having
trouble
understanding what it what it's asking
walt went to the desert because hank was
barbecuing his money
gus went to the laundry because lalo was
barbecuing his plan to make it his make
it on his own i i thought when i first
read it i said make it his own um so it
was kind of throwing me off
um
yeah the use of the word barbecue right
it's a little unsettling that that word
in there it
throws me off a little bit
but i mean
so
yeah what is what are we what are you
saying well i think in this context
barbecuing basically means
interfering he was uh hank was
interfering in walt's attempt to in his
actual money that he has there and in
gus's case he's trying to make money and
law is putting a stop to that so both of
them went out there
for the for the purposes of rescuing
their money from an outside force
[Music]
okay
coleco thank you for the 9.99 does
anyone think mike absolutely failed in
his security approach
i i don't mean to laugh at your question
but i i just it uh this is becoming a
recurring uh
recurring one today lalo outsmarted him
at every single aspect not sure why gus
would continue to trust someone with
such poor judgment and then it has a
little smiley face at the end
um
yeah so
when i was reading that i was thinking
okay well we kind of went over this and
yeah it it i like the little smiley face
at the end to lighten the thought of
that
there's really
you know
lalo the the the moral of this or the uh
the the thing about this is that lala
was a
a fine adversary
against gus which is a pretty hard thing
to come about you know to come up with
because gus is so
good at what he does so
yeah
diego diaz thank you for the 499 do you
think there will be parallels between
jesse's ptsd and kim's ptsd just like
jessie after shooting gail kim seemed
lifeless at the end
i don't know if it'll be a one-to-one
but i think there will be some some
similarities um
she didn't have to to kill anybody with
her own hands but she was certainly
willing to do that if if if she had to
and um
you know i think that you know that
that's sort of like the you know the
just sort of the unintended consequences
and the way they affect things you know
the way that they affect things that you
you know you can't really forecast when
you're planning you know you can't
really ex can't you can't really take
them into account and they really
end up messing you up in the end
my
feeling about this is uh
i don't think we're gonna see much in
terms of kim having
she was in immediate shock
but once the dust is settled i think
we're gonna see
kim
double down on the life that she's
leading toward
which means like i said earlier
compartmentalization and and i think
that's going to potentially create even
a bigger rift between her and
and saul
yeah i mean even uh i think one of the
exciting well for me the exciting thing
about this show is always this question
in a more general sense just how are
these characters going to handle this
what choices are they going to make and
that's one of the things i love about
this season is that some of the what you
would normally call climaxes are
happening episodes before the finale so
now we get to see the actual fallout how
are they going to handle this
and i don't really draw a one-to-one
connection p like you said between
jesse and kim both of them have gone
through traumatic experiences but
they're two very different characters
so yeah there is a big question how is
kim going to handle this what is the
choice she makes next i mean she was
like pretty actively choosing this life
and she had so many opportunities not to
uh jesse felt much more like a victim
yeah and kim has got she's made of stern
stuff i mean don't let's i think the big
takeaway from this episode is she is
totally right or die she was going to
pull that trigger and
there was no question that she was going
through with it and i have some ideas
about like how she might react going
beyond this it might be a little bit of
a spoiler because it's based on one of
the teasers so i won't talk about it um
just yet but there's some dialogue in
the most recent uh teaser that reminds
me very much of a very very specific
scene in breaking bad that i think gives
a little context to it
yeah
i'm curious to find out what that is
next week
yeah
um yeah like i said beforehand if uh
if gil and adam um they'll they'll
probably step out at a certain point and
then
we can talk a little bit about that
afterwards because i want to talk about
that too
once the spoil sports league you guys
can have your fun yeah
since the people with some kind of
self-restraint who who can wait for the
whole week without trying to to figure
out what's going on with uh
[Laughter]
uh josh willis says something that i've
seen quite a few other people on there
saying um
thank you for the 9.99 have any of you
guys wondered what they did with the
bodies of gus's men that lalo killed and
the answer my answer would be no um
i didn't think about it more than like i
i figured they have a process for that
you know like
for other you know whenever they
whenever there's uh
gang stuff or cartel stuff or whatever
when people get killed they have a
process and i i just you know i didn't
really think about it
what about you guys
i thought about it a little bit because
i saw a question like why didn't they
get buried in the hole with howard and
lalo and the way i see it was they had
to hide howard and lalo they had to make
sure those bodies were never found and
these were gusses and moreover mike's
guys so um these are i'm sure their
families are going to be well
compensated maybe a private memorial
service i can't imagine that they would
allow their men to be heaped into a hole
in the bottom of a lab so i imagine
they'll have another way of disposing of
the bodies
yeah
yeah i agree with that i think
there's a lot less uh at stake in terms
of
uh completely hiding them
forever the way it happened with the
lalo and howard
also there was a funny theory floating
around in the chat in our live stream
last night which is uh you know maybe
pois or manos is about to have a new
mystery meet special
gus did not want to waste resources yeah
yeah i don't know about that but i i do
agree that you know like the the the
main takeaway i had what i thought about
that was the reason they're showing us
burying them is because of the
importance of making them disappear
whereas the other guys they'll figure it
out because you know they're
professional you know they do things
professionally so it's not like a loose
end in my mind
uh max adamski says
thank you for the two dollars thanks uh
pete you are one of you are the spiciest
pepper in my daily diet all right
that's cool the carolina reaper of
better call
i'm glad glad to to
be able to be that um
radio chaos thank you for the 10
canadian do you think mike holds jimmy
somewhat responsible for howard's death
which leads to their more
contentious relationship in breaking bad
i don't know if that's the the main
factor um
i thought that there was a little
undercurrent of like
mike being disgusted with them whenever
he he said that's the lie you were
telling right but um
i don't i don't think that that
i don't know i it didn't it i didn't
connect those dots right away from that
i don't think mike is like overtly or
has very strong thoughts on it but i do
think
uh
if you were to ask him about it he would
say this is like
well you could say it in a mic voice but
but ago
these are like childish games that
they're playing and that's such an
irresponsible time to do it
and i think he knows that howard doesn't
deserve it uh he probably just because
of his investigation work he probably
knows uh who howard is to an extent and
also he might have known him on a on a
minor personal level as the parking
attendant at howard may have tried true
house
i'm sure howard always had the right
number of stickers too i bet they never
argued over it yeah
justine browning thank you for the five
dollars uh thinking back to kim crying
when she read chuck's letter to jimmy
and him not showing any emotion there
may be a similar split reaction to
howard yeah and this is something that i
had mentioned and um
i thought it was interesting what you
said adam about her doubling down
i do think that she doubles down on the
relationship but i'm not sure
that
it's as easy as as it sounds you know
what i mean i think that there's going
to be
um
i i feel like if i feel like she
understood that there was a there was
something going on with jimmy that that
you know she felt like she wanted to
you know she wanted to help him through
that situation with chuck
i think the more that you see of this it
starts to look like well this person is
just broken and maybe i can't do
anything about it
do you know what i mean
like i think she understands like that
that jimmy you know i think there will
be different i i think there will be
different reactions to to answer what
the um
the question is saying
but then i i what i'm what i've been
wondering about more is like
you know does she
does she think that she has to get away
from him because they're not
they're not able to
to function in that same way anymore
i don't know
i think that's a huge i yeah i think
and it's going to be tough to make a
solid prediction on this because
uh
interestingly enough and i think a lot
of shows can't pull this off but this
show managed to create
something extremely suspenseful
suspenseful out of the relationship
between these two characters like for me
one of the biggest cliffhangers we have
is
what happens to their relationship
and i don't even mean it in like kind of
the dramatic romantic way i mean in
terms of like
they're not just husband and wife but
they've been friends for a very long
time and have so many shared experiences
and have such a deep connection
i really have no idea what's gonna
happen
yeah well i mean none of us do but
the more i think about it the more i
think it's been
pretty pretty foreshadowed that jimmy's
gonna be the one if they break up to
remove himself from the situation trying
out of fear for her you know safety and
wanting to protect her i think that's
been really well established and
certainly what just happened um
might be
might be the clincher for him
is one uh nuanced and when you were
saying that she was kind of moving
towards this life and there's potential
for her to double down
i do think that there is some strong
compartmentalization that gets broken
down here a bit where she in her mind i
don't think was thinking cartel when
they were going after howard
um
and there definitely is a wall there
where she knows that jimmy's involved in
that stuff but she thought that they
were going to bruise howard and that's
that this is a major unintended
consequence
so
i guess it just puts a big question mark
on what's her reaction going to be
i i don't know that it's going to be
yeah i guess i don't know if it's going
to be the kind of doubling down we've
seen in the past where she pulls these
scams and then is so enticed by it she
wants to do more
i just really don't know i think less
that less of a petty doubling down more
doubling down in terms of like she might
get more serious
about doing things like kind of in the
criminal world
and i don't think that necessarily means
she like becomes an executive at
madrigal for example but like that kind
of thing is not out of the question
um ostrom1980 thank you for the two
dollars he asks um would can be the top
candidate to replace hamlin and i would
say that that's a
definitely a no um she hasn't worked
there
anymore and i think the main thing there
i think that they'll they'll probably
dissolve the firm um you know he was
he was the last of the named uh partners
in the and the um hhm so i think that
everything that they've gone through
first with chuck and then now with this
situation it would make more sense for
them to dissolve the firm and and you
know
whoever else is there
start up something different
um
there was something that i wanted to
let's see
one of the things about you know what
you were saying about kim
and her future
i mean
the
it'll be interesting to see how
like
i guess if they do go into that backlash
around around the uh the howard thing
like how people react to it but i'm just
not really convinced that they're going
to do that so we'll see
um suzbee art
thank you for the 4.99 well we see tuko
price gail kim's dad jeff nachos papa
skateboard bros from the first episode
i would say
no uh i was the only person on my list
that i feel certain we're gonna see
but i'll say i think this is probably
the uh last question for me adam this is
gonna be the one we go out on and i
think pete you're we're starting to see
that you maybe don't even need bullets
because there are so many questions and
so many so many things people are
itching to talk about that's what he's
diffusing up all the time
but i agree with all of your answers but
i would just modify gail to maybe i
agree with that and skateboard bro is
just a fun tidbit if anyone listens to
the insider podcast or reads interviews
with tom schnauz have already heard this
but when they brainstormed ideas for the
howard scheme one of the ideas they had
in the writers room was to bring in the
skateboard twins and that maybe they
would have one of them get hit by
howard's car make him think he killed
one of them yeah i don't know how fully
formed the idea was but we almost saw
them and now that we didn't i think we
probably won't maybe in slip and jimmy
if they do a second season
all right so you guys are gonna um you
guys are gonna tap out
yeah i think we'll tap out here um but
i'll be back next week and uh thanks as
always pete for having us on yeah this
is great
yeah courtney is great being part of a
conversation with you and getting to
meet you likewise
yeah and i i agree that i you know that
the time i don't make bullet points is
going to be the time whenever we'll
absolutely need them
but yeah we've gotten less effective of
getting through and um
you know i mean like it was like i was
explaining to courtney earlier you know
i want to have a thing where i can have
a conversation and bring people on you
know uh talk to different people
about this stuff that i'm i'm so
absorbed in all the time and
the other thing is i want to you know
have a place where people can interact
with with us so you know one side wins
out it it's not really a loss you know
what i mean but um
you know that's the way that it played
out and i'm glad everybody's here and
asking questions and i'm glad you guys
were here today and um adam if you're
not able to make it back us or gil
i don't know why i always call you gus
gil
i'm looking at it on my screen right now
and intimidating demeanor that's right
yeah yeah but uh if you don't if you
aren't able to come he said you might
not be able to come back before the end
of the season so uh it's good to have
one more i hope i will i i believe for
the next couple weeks that uh at least
for the next two weeks you'll probably
see me so
oh okay well that's good then um if you
want to plug anything as now's the
chance and um
courtney you're gonna stay around for a
little bit longer is that right
okay
cool yeah and i'll just say um
youtube channel one take that's where
you'll see all of our video essays and
things like that
uh we also do fun stuff uh we just did a
live trivia night for better call saul
last night yeah it was like a free free
premiere watch party
yeah exactly so we try to have fun over
there and then the cameo i think this is
something you really genuinely but fans
of miracles all want to see this because
it's it's almost like extra content no
it was pretty cool that we uh for the
trivia night i figured we need to have
somebody to oversee the proceedings make
sure there are no shenanigans so we got
a district attorney in there but you
might know bill oakley
uh we had the actor peter um uh he was
in character and he did some
interstitials throughout the night so
that was a very cool as a fan of the
show to get that was one of the coolest
moments of my life
absolutely i had no idea i was busy all
day yesterday making the video so i
didn't didn't check that out but that's
cool as hell
yeah that's awesome i'm gonna have to
check that out
cool thank you guys and uh thanks for
having us yeah thanks everyone in the
chat look forward to talking to you all
again soon
all right all right see ya
see ya
okay guten tag thank you for the 199
euro in breaking bad season 5 episode 1
they find two bodies after the explosion
um
that doesn't sound correct to me
season five episode one that's meaning
at the at the nursing home at casa
tranquila is that
i think
what i what i interpreted this is that
they're saying that after
uh gus
or after
walt and jesse burn down the lab they
find two bodies
oh cause i that's um right after first
episode back after season the four
finale when they killed gus in the
nursing home and there's three bodies
recovered right ah oh yeah well that
would make sense um
that i think that might be what they're
confusing because i don't think they
ever mentioned
them finding bodies at the lab
i made his army thank you for the pound
one pound 79.
in my opinion 609 will start with the
something stupid montage i think that's
a very good guess
i i think that you're
i understand the uh
where you're coming from with that
i think i think we're due for one and um
this would be a good timing for
it oh let's see
do you want to add anything to that
courtney well i i just can't imagine
that they would use the same song again
because they've used something stupid
previously did they don't typically
reuse songs do they
no i think what the what the question is
asking or is saying is that they'll do a
split screen where they should oh oh
okay okay all right yeah gotcha like
showing like how they're reacting to
yeah like they did it you know first
whenever they in season four when they
were sort of drifting apart and they did
it whenever they were in the you know he
was in the desert
and uh beginning of 509.
daniel ventura thank you for the 499 how
do you think they will make the
transition into breaking bad universe
time skip
since we saw
since we saw saul in his mansion in the
season six trailer
um i think that they'll show
i think it'll be just flash forwards i
don't think that they
i don't think they need to like give
some detailed description of everything
that's going on it just needs to make
sense
that this is at a different time and um
yeah i do think that they'll end up
showing him right before
because of that teaser where they show
them in in the mansion um but i'm not
sure otherwise you know they have a they
have a lot that they can work with there
do you have a favorite pet theory
courtney
for this um
one of the things i like is like that
they would show something that happens
in the breaking bad timeline but from
jimmy's perspective so i like the idea
of maybe him like being out in the
desert on his knees with the it wasn't
me it was ignacio line um maybe seen
something behind the scenes there
a little bit but i agree with you i mean
we only have five episodes left and
we're still i think about four years
before the breaking bad timeline
officially begins so they're gonna have
to start jumping forward so
i don't know i don't i don't really have
any favorite pet theories on on this one
or how they're gonna accomplish it
yeah there's so many options it's hard
to really you know it's hard to like
nail one down
ud reviews thank you for the 4.99 kim on
the bed hair down pink clothes
head down listening to mike felt also
like a little
kimmy finally getting in trouble yeah i
like that it's um
you know it
that they're they're still
i i don't know they had that flash
forward um there's still potential that
there'll be another flash forward where
we get a little bit more about her
background
but that's one of the questions i had
after that is you know is she learning
that
if she does things a certain way she can
get away with it i mean she she also
kind of resents her mother so there's a
you know there's like that that that
internal conflict of like okay this is
good that i'm not getting in trouble i'm
still getting the thing that i want but
i kind of hate that it was my mom who
made that happen by being you know the
way she is kind of deal
and so yeah there's that resolution of
like well maybe that's you know sort of
why she still wears those those earrings
and you know why she's drawn to jimmy
and you know why she's really turned on
by the whole idea of running the scams
yeah ud is great i've i've collabed with
ud in the past um that's an interesting
take so like the head down listening to
mike so like she's finally getting the
the discipline that maybe she was
craving from her
her mom i didn't i didn't read it that
way personally i think she's like in
such like existential shock
uh about what just happened and um
i i agree with with what we've been
talking about though so far it's really
hard to predict
how kim is going to
what this is going to do to her
yeah i think visually i i totally get
what ud is saying here like they're you
know i mean visually
it's very reminiscent of what what she
looked like when she was waiting for
them to come in in that room
but yeah
but i also see what you're saying about
like it she's kind of in a whole
different place as far as as where
they're at
thank you for that uh sachin paul thank
you for the 4.99 at what point do all
these callbacks to breaking bad
at what point do all these callbacks to
breaking bad become fanservicey kind of
becoming tired of everything being a
nudge nudge wink wink
um i think they've been pretty tasteful
uh
i think that
i don't know what would be the point it
hasn't reached it yet for me
how about you
of course yeah no it doesn't it doesn't
feel fan service um probably like the
only moment that ever felt fanservicey
to me was when they brought hank and
gomey back and they have their little
banter in the locker room before they go
and talk to
um crazy8 but i didn't even really think
of that as to fanservice because it was
furthering the plot of um how like you
know uh he becomes like a an informant
for them at that point but that's the
only time it ever felt remotely
fanservicey to me
yeah i thought that felt a little bit um
unnecessary and also tuco you know in
the very beginning uh they they ended up
putting him into they ended up you know
making him a part of the story but i
think those are the two worst examples
of
of when you know
but i you know i'm willing to i'm
willing to let it go i mean i was really
excited to see
hank and gomi come back and i i like you
said i i i think it did still serve its
purpose so you can't really
it wasn't it wasn't just for that you
know yes some people in the comments
were saying maybe it was the line it
wasn't me it was ignacio like how he
started to say that so maybe that was
yeah
some of some of those lines that we hear
yeah aaron stevens thank you for the
a299 was there significance
to baking soda in the fridge
i don't know i mean in the states people
just put that in there all the time
as a way to
what is the purpose of that to
absorb bad odors
yeah odors and moisture maybe too or i
don't know is it just about the smells i
think it's more about the smell
yeah
it's like yeah that's just
it's probably something that the the
company arm and hammer made up you know
is like oh you really need this our
product for this great thing that it
does so they could sell a lot more of it
but it worked you know i mean
because i remember you know
everyone every house that you go to they
have one of those in there
a
s h x r k i e 12.
thank you for the five dollars it kind
of sucks to think about how walt and
jesse cook over lalo and howard's bodies
that's intentional
yeah it's definitely something that they
wanted us to think about and it does
suck i agree completely
and i thought it was a pretty good thing
it's funny because that theory was so
on like people hated it you know
everyone kept saying that it was gonna
he was gonna be buried in the south wall
and and like on reddit you know people
were just like this is the worst thing
ever i'll you know it'll ruin the series
if it happens and
it seems like it it worked pretty good
to me you know
yeah i agree
and derek taylor thank you for the five
dollars do you think the bodies of lalo
and howard will be found by the fbi uh
we touched on this already i don't think
so but it's a possibility
um
dracaerus [ __ ]
thank you for the 4.99
it's disgusting howard is buried next to
his murder forever they'll need to find
their bodies without a tip off mike knew
and he died in breaking bad season five
yeah i don't i don't know i mean
if it makes sense to to bring that in
like we kind of talked about this if it
makes sense to have them discovered then
i'm not against it you know what i mean
but i don't think it needs to happen
yeah you know that's howard's story it
it it sucks you know what i mean like
it's it's tragic and it's sad and and it
worked in that way you know
all right
soft batch exclamation point thank you
for the five dollars do you did you
think for a second that the doc patching
up gus would be the vet i did
i was uh i was looking at that whenever
they they pulled out if it would be him
and it wasn't um what do you think
courtney
i didn't know
yeah i didn't think um it would be
caldera patching up because strictly
because he said he was done with uh yeah
with that
yeah he did say that and that's why i
thought it would be like oh that's a
that's that's interesting that they
pulled him back in but it didn't turn
out to be that way
the one thing i wondered um because i
know you said you're going to be getting
going soon too
were you ever
when you went to see it in tribeca where
you ever
in fear of kim's life whenever she went
to
to gus's house
i don't know that i
no when i saw that that mike tackled her
no i wasn't i wasn't in fear of her for
her then it was up until that point i
was i was afraid of what lalo might do
to her
and um
i was afraid that they might have at one
point i thought they might send kim like
into the lab not at this while watching
this episode i mean this is like a
stupid theory i had a long time ago
something i was speculating about
um so no actually like i i wasn't ever
really afraid that this was going to be
the end of kim because i was so certain
it was going to be the end of lalo
yeah that's what i was going to say and
that uh
i was kind of disappointed that we
didn't get to talk to to everyone about
that but i i thought that maybe when
they were writing the story that that
was part of that was you know that was
supposed to be part of the tension is
kim going to get out of this alive but
when i'm watching it i never felt that
way exactly what you said there
i was just like okay how are they going
to kill lolo you know what i mean how
are they going to get out of this
because the aftermath seems so important
you know what i mean the aftermath
of the two episodes that were were
happening in you know one right after
the other that it just didn't it didn't
occur to me that whenever she left the
house that she might be in danger at all
and i and i do wonder if that was
you know part of their intention
whenever they were writing things that
were that we were supposed to be like oh
my god is kim gonna get killed whenever
she goes over there
yeah i mean
go ahead i was gonna say it's certainly
certainly reasonable to be worried about
kim though for sure i mean there's a lot
of ways that could have gone wrong
yeah absolutely i mean that's
that's part of the the dna of the show
for sure is
please don't let anything happen to kim
but in that particular i thought that's
why i thought it was kind of interesting
when i thought about after the fact i
was like
you know i i don't think that she you
know yeah i thought it was crazy that
jimmy
at first that jimmy suggested she went
said she'd go but i know at the same
time i never really thought that it
would come to anything
doggone thank you for the 999 brilliant
scene of throwing lalo in the hole with
no regard
with the howard music comes on and mike
tells them be careful
showing that howard wasn't supposed to
be there and evoking viewer emotions
i agree 100 i thought that was a nice
touch i listened to the um
insider podcast and they said that they
wrote that
that piece of music it was actually for
the the teaser and and then they they
decided whenever they were putting the
scene together that it would work there
but yeah i thought it went really well
and i think overall i thought that the
sound in this um the the sound and some
of those music cues they stood out to me
more than i mean usually those
are always there and they're always
working really well but
i i noticed them a lot more in this
episode you know like i to add to the
tone when i was watching it
yeah agreed and i think i meant i talked
a little bit about the scene earlier and
how
um
and with how like it meant
so much to mike i think putting his body
down in there
and
having that moment
mr z thank you for the five dollars
canadian pg said that peter gould i
guess said that in season six mike goes
as dark as is possible and that gus
finds love have these hints come to
fruition yet if not how will they that's
the question i've asked myself a lot
um
that gus filings loved one definitely
stood out to me before the you know he
he put these out right before the season
started
and i don't know that i that i've i
would relate anything that's happened to
him finding love
what is your take on that courtney do
you think that that that we've seen that
yet
no and i mean i think this is something
like many people have wanted to know
since we've seen breaking bad we know
that there are children at some point
unless he just has like kids toys and
his house has some sort of weird cover
um
it seems that he will have children
at some point um with whom that's that's
the question so i don't know maybe
that's something that they will will
develop i don't think there's been
[Music]
any
i also wanted to ask you
courtney before um
before you go uh about this that it
seems like the the this pop this theory
of um
gus
taking kim in you know like putting her
giving her a job has gotten really
popular of late and i'm not a real big
fan of the of that
but i mean he did they did meet each
other for the first time here in this
episode um i don't know how you get from
that to being like hey she would be a
great asset asset to this corporation or
whatever you know what i mean
yeah i'm not sure i mean and to be just
to clarify they don't actually really
meet she hears his voice on the phone
and he never identifies himself
so
she doesn't know who he is or even he
meets the fake gus briefly yeah yeah the
fake goes he wants to you know i'm
supposed to shoot you that was funny um
i don't know i mean i think it's it's
it's possible that he might notice her i
mean it's to her husband though that
she's so loyal so that's not gonna
really i think impress him necessarily
but uh i think it's an interesting
thought i'm i'm not gonna necessarily
rule that out i think there are a lot of
different possibilities it's not one
that i
personally subscribe to i don't really
see that happening but you never know
yeah i i guess what i don't like about
the
about the theory is that it it kind of
requires them to both still be around
but not together and i don't really
understand how that that that
you know like how that all fits you know
like unless
unless gus was like taking her
as a type of hostage you know like where
he was
you know keeping having putting her to
work against her will and then jimmy has
to continue doing what he's doing so
that you know nothing bad happens to her
but that seems like really
overly complicated and and not terribly
satisfying
um as far as mike goes as dark as is
possible i i don't know i mean he's he's
gone to some places with with
with nachos especially i think you know
like he
he beat him up before they took them out
there he he served them up to
you know die i mean i think they could
be referring to that but um
i'm not sure he i mean he was being
purposeful it was like he was being
vague on purpose and
leaving things up to interpretation i'm
not sure that we've we've hit those
marks yet
alex thanks for the five dollars do we
think kim will handle the pts
how do we think kim will handle the ptsd
now that she's had her desert moment i'm
sure it will be an issue
but hard to see her just running away
yeah that's what that's what this that's
one of the things that i really loved
about this episode was that
it made a lot of that stuff seem a lot
harder you know they
they
they threw in so hard for each other
it makes it a little bit more hard it
makes it a little harder to figure out
how they they slip away from each other
now you know
yeah and so i keep going back to days of
wine and roses and the significance of
the song and of the film and um how jack
lemmon lee uh leaves his his wife in
that film um
because she can't get better to protect
her and i don't i just like i don't
think you can take anything one for one
i think it does give us some context and
some way of understanding what's going
to happen and i can see how this
would really um this this experience
would would move jimmy to distance
himself from her to try to protect her
um in that way and as far as is it okay
if i talk about the teaser or would you
rather yeah absolutely okay so the
teaser yeah but just real quick if you
don't want to know about teasers this is
your chance to uh check out because
we're going to talk about yeah some
speculation on what we saw in the last
um official teaser they put out
yeah so at the end of last night's
episode it's the black and white teaser
and we hear jimmy speaking i'm assuming
to kim where he says it gets easier with
time
do you guys know what i'm talking about
have you seen it pete
oh yeah i saw it sorry i was reading a
comment um
yeah so
i was a little distracted he mentions
that it gets it gets easier with time
right right um kind of just like like i
think talking about like whatever trauma
she's feeling or ptsd that she's feeling
following the howard situation and what
i was mentioning earlier what it reminds
me of is there's um i think it's uh a
season five episode two and breaking bad
magical it's right after um the thing
with uh ted benneke happens
and
shortly after uh
mike um not mike i'm so tired i'm like
losing my words here when waltz blows up
the the nursing home and and skyler
finds out about it she's like really
horrified by the whole thing right and
so she like falls into this funk into
this depression she won't get out of bed
there's like three or four straight
episodes where skyler just stays in bed
and um in that episode walt gets into
into bed with her and he's trying to
talk to her like you're going to get
over it it's going to get easier with
time and it's almost like verbatim word
for word the same dialogue that we hear
in this teaser so i just thought that
was really interesting and that is
interesting and i hadn't thought about
it because what i thought of initially
and i don't mean to interrupt but
i'll let you go back i just wanted to
throw it in there that what i thought
about initially was when he goes to mike
when he's having a similar problem in
bcs you know and he says when will this
get better
yeah
and yeah so i thought he was sort of i
thought as far as what jimmy's saying
he's echoing you know he's parroting
what what mike told him
yeah and just like he hurts him with
like the bad choice road thing so he
borrows a lot of mike's uh speeches
which is funny because it it hasn't
worked for him yet there hasn't even
been enough time for it to work he's
just saying it to say it you know what i
mean
which is interesting and then i i do
like what what you're talking about here
about bringing up you know walt and and
skyler because it was showing that they
were different you know i mean that walt
was able to was able to to look at this
stuff as like necessary
and look past the
the depres like the depravity involved
and and you know uh his wife wasn't able
to do that the same way
yeah i mean she eventually does come to
terms with it she does get over it get
over it but
i again i don't think you can say like
that's a way to read what's going to
because skyler and kim are completely
different characters of course
but i think it's it's just interesting
context and like how do characters react
to these sorts of things in this world
so
i don't know but it may also be that
like this isn't necessarily like kim's
first rodeo with something really
dramatic happening so i keep thinking of
something that peter gould said during
the talking saul episode after the um
[Music]
right after the the finale the season
the mid-season finale where he said he
imagined that kim like left her her town
of red cloud in like flames
so i don't know that she might have like
an interesting past where maybe
something else dramatic has happened
yeah i do think that's an important part
of all of this is that there's a reason
why she ran
yeah there's one there's what she told
rich schweikart which is that she wanted
more and that she thought she was going
to get stuck there and there's probably
some truth to that because there's
always you know some truth that makes a
good lie
but there could be something much more
substantial
that we haven't we haven't seen yet i
agree with that and i'm very curious
with that because
that would tell us a lot about what she
might do in this situation right yeah
because
you know like
you think um
she she you know she she
jimmy could push her away because he
thinks it's better like in sort of in
the situation that you're talking about
she could leave him for that same reason
or or she could you know if this is a
pattern that she's had in her life and
and and and you know you kind of think
of that thing of like i'm gonna fix it
myself i fix it myself like that that
that that
attitude she has um earlier in
the series
and you can
you kind of can see that that coming
into play too you know like where she's
gonna she's gonna say i need to i need
to run because it's gonna be better you
know for for jimmy but that's just a way
of coping with it you know what i mean
yeah that's a good point yeah so
i can see her
also wanting to fix things herself and
saving herself she even says at one
point i saved me so um i know ariel
levine um
who uh wrote the uh the episode where we
see kim with her earrings and uh she
mentioned that they had an original they
originally had a different cold open for
that and it was supposed to be like kim
leaving red cloud or getting to
albuquerque like one of those two
so i think we might actually get that
teaser elsewhere in the season maybe
like the next episode for that reason
that you were just saying like to help
give us context for how kim might react
to this situation
so if we see like what she was leaving
and how she coped with maybe another
difficult situation that might give some
context to how she would cope with this
perhaps yeah and i'm not sure i saw that
same one but i did see something from
peter gould where he said they had a
different teaser and it really explained
everything about who she was and they
thought it was too much they were giving
away too much information so they scaled
it back to the
shoplifting scene instead
matt
uh thank you for the 199 concerned about
jesse and walt's aged looks no that
that's not something that bothers me at
all i mean
we've been looking at jonathan banks as
mike for
uh six seasons now and it doesn't bother
me really i mean i i know it's a i know
it he looks different
if i go back and watch breaking bad it
you know there's a little bit of a wow
okay yeah this was uh supposed to be
later and it it it doesn't match up the
continuity is not great but it's not
something that bothers me
they're good actors and they give them
good material to work with it's a lot
more
important than if they have you know
like i remember people talking about the
uh bald cap for for el camino and it's
like something like that just doesn't
take me out of it you know
yeah i agree and i'm not concerned about
it at all it's it takes a good degree of
suspension of disbelief i mean it's uh
you know it's been like 10-15 years so
of course they're all gonna be older and
watching uh some of breaking bad over
the weekend and looking at like gus and
mike and i'm like wow they were so much
younger but you know it doesn't really
matter all right that's that's gonna be
the last one for me i'm gonna head out
and get myself to bed it's been a long
day for me but pete thank you so much
for having me on i had a blast and uh
thank you everyone watching um for the
questions and for having me on the
channel
really yeah well
we'll have you back i mean we have um we
have a a few different people that we
like to rotate in and out and um
i'm glad that we we had a conversation
uh
you know off camera that i thought would
you know the some stuff that we might
talk about maybe we'll do a video a
regular video instead of the stream but
we'll definitely have you back on the
stream it was great having you here glad
you were able to do it um
definitely get yourself some rest now
it's late at night where you're at and
um
i'll just for everyone else i'm going to
try to get through i'll definitely get
through all of these questions that are
here
and i'll stay for as long as that takes
and um you know we'll all be back uh
next week
so do you want to just plug your channel
one more time or anything else before
you go
yeah sure uh courtney's reviews um i
have not yet made my uh breakdown for
this episode i work full time so
it takes me a little bit longer to get
those up but uh yeah come check me out
if you like talking about better
colossal i think you all do and uh yeah
again thanks for having me um had a
blast and i'll see you
in the cyber
yeah yeah we'll talk soon thanks again
have a good one
all right it's arthur miller thank you
for the r 10
if you had to choose one breaking bad
moment that is rel relevant for saul's
story and should appear again in bcs
from saul's perspective
what would it be i you know this is
something that i i go back and forth on
i can't really
pin myself down on on one i mean
i i think like i said earlier that what
i would like for it that i i would just
like you know if they're going to do
this rashem on effect thing where we see
something from a different perspective
that that changes uh you know how we
experience it
then i just i just really do want it to
be through
through saul's perspective um
i and i and i and i mean i i'm holding
out a little bit of hope that
once jim and kimmy or kim and jimmy
split up that there'll be some
some
chance at redemption either individually
or
together of them coming back together so
i'm hoping that
you know
the way i look at it is the way
right now
all evidence points to him being the
saul that he was being the kind of
kind of slimy character sleazy character
he was is a response to not being able
to deal with all of what's happening to
him in his life right now
kim leaving or kim being absent is is
something that would add to that
so i guess
what i would like to see is something in
the breaking bad timeline
reframed so that we still see is there
some jimmy mcgill left in there you know
because that would that would be in
service of him coming back before the
end of the series
because when you watch breaking bad and
you just think about what you see there
it's not 100 clear that there's any
jimmy mcgill there i mean there's
there's there's a few scenes that you
see where he he he seems a little less
soul and maybe a little more like jimmy
but
you know it's it's an open question as
far as i'm concerned so
we'll have to wait and see how that
plays out
richard callaway thank you for the five
dollars can you guys guess what might
happen in the four years before the
breaking bad timeline starts it's 24
2004 which is that's definitely true
and walt's 50th birthday is september
2008. um
i think that it's just he
you know obviously
kim is gone
kim gets uh the relationship breaks down
one way or the other
that could happen really quickly uh
we're not we might not need to jump too
far ahead for that to happen
and then he just settles into being saul
you know like he by the time we meet him
he he's been that way for a few years so
um
he basically has to to live in that you
know
that's all that i really see that is
necessary
um
kim has to leave his life so that he
doesn't have that thing to to hold on to
anymore that old part of himself
and from there it's just a progression
until he he meets walter white and gets
in
you know to that situation
big ralph thank you for the ten dollars
completely disagree that kim will handle
this better than jimmy
kim has never had to deal with one of
her plans going south like jimmy has go
back and watch the scene with kim and
jimmy on the bed
uh there's some
i mean as far as we know that she's
never had to deal with that we don't
really know about her past which is what
we were just talking about
a few minutes ago there might be more
there than what we know about so
i don't know if you could say that for
sure
i think jimmy has more experience and
you know
but he also anything he just sort of uh
suppresses it and you know there's a
that usually comes out in bad ways later
whenever you do it like that but we'll
wait and see i mean i don't
i think it's it's it's a fantastic place
to be at with these two characters
aries area ozone thank you for the 499
what do you think happens to hhm and
will resolving sandpiper money be much
of a plot point
getting lawyers like cliff involved um
i think hhm will be dissolved they
didn't really they didn't really exist
in breaking bad we never heard about it
so
i don't think they need to say much more
about that and i think the sandpiper
money will explain why he lives in that
ridiculous mansion so i do think they'll
get that
i don't know if there's going to be
any real and i don't know if it's going
to involve a lot of people getting you
know bringing back a lot of characters
for like a whole another side story
there i feel like we know that it's
gonna happen
so they don't have to but it'll depend
on you know
really what's going on with uh
kim and jimmy personally
and what you know what comes to them
splitting apart
michael keith thank you for the five
dollars love me some peppers live stream
question do you subscr to subscribe to
the lyle is heisenberg theory
um
i think
lyle i don't think you should
underestimate lyle that's what i think
that would be my answer to that question
the ref thank you for the five dollars
prediction kim eventually goes to the
police gus hears word of it
and has his men capture her then mike is
the one who has to pull the trigger
um
i mean maybe
i
i don't know if that solves their
problem as cleanly as they would want it
to
and i don't know that they really set up
anything
you know other than their one meeting
where he says she's made of sterner
stuff that it would really
matter um
it would be hard just because of the
fact that she is a civilian
and
it's the howard thing is a pretty clear
case of unintended consequences of the
cartel swooping in and
changing it up you know like i don't i
don't know i don't know if that makes
perfect sense that
i i don't know if there's a lot of drama
in that
jeffrey tal
townen
thank you for the 10 canadian kim
becomes unnerved and therefore a problem
for mike i bet him or jimmy kill her
again i just don't think that that's a
very satisfying ending this story is not
about
you know um
it's not about about a b you know stuff
that's problems for gus or mike it's
it's about jimmy and kim
so i hope they have something better and
planned than that but we'll wait and see
sorry i have to scroll here um
yeah
formula four four four four eight eight
eight thank you for the 4.99 since
wallow is dead who is the main villain
going to be
um it depends on which timeline we're
talking about i mean i guess we already
know gus is the main villain in
the breaking bad timeline
plus walter white of course and in the
gene timeline i think it's going to be
jeff
i guess they they have
confirmed that they recast the actor but
i expect that that will be and then
after they tie that up
the question is is whether jimmy was
going to turn himself in and if he's
going to go back to albuquerque or
what happens then
i don't think they need to i mean i
don't know i mean they are going to
bring carol burnett in she could be a a
uh she could definitely be a
a villain but i don't know that they
need to replace lalo i i think it's
one of the things we didn't really get
to talk about but i think that there's
i think it's
it's nice that they cleared that out
that they that they
that they ended that part of the story
so that they could open up and and this
could actually be different i don't know
that they need to interject another
villain because these two people
are already um you know they're already
feeling the effects the and they'll be
living in the aftermath of what's
happened because of what they the
choices that they made
all right um
a lot of comments here i'll try to get
to what we have uh
randy wallen thank you for the five
dollars loose ends will they be killed
pi who delivered photos
video crew
i don't think so um
i mean howard's howard is going to go
down as
you know
i don't know the pi is kind of
interesting the video crew
they can't do that i i
i mean that they're just too established
but
i i don't know i mean you bring up i
guess what i'm thinking about is from
your question is that
it's interesting that mike knows that
all those people are involved
but um
yeah i don't i don't see them going in
that direction
if they do something to the to the video
crew i'd be pretty pretty bummed the pi
just isn't all that important
so we'll see
rolo rollo thank you for the mx 100 the
two bodies in the burnt lab in breaking
bad season five were of the guy in the
elevator and the one guarding jesse
they couldn't id them because the teeth
do this popcorn thing oh okay
yeah now that's starting to ring a bell
yeah either way like i said i read in
you know an interview yesterday where
they said that they didn't think about
the bodies being discovered after the
fire
so i just kind of shut down my my
thoughts on that um
but this is in relation to that other
question so yeah that makes sense thanks
for that
maximum rock and roll thank you for the
five dollars to my favorite youtubers
collaborate and keep up the good work to
both of you
i believe that's in
relation to courtney and yeah it was
nice to have her have her on
you guys were
giving me
problems about not knowing who she was
in the last stream and she reached out
and we had a
conversation
and i'll definitely continue to have
them involved the biggest problem i have
with that is you know
i don't my i like talking about the show
i like talking about more people talking
to more people about it those are all
things i like the problem i have is if
we have too many of them
it's hard to
to um
at one time you know what i mean it's
hard to have everybody be able to chime
in so
that's really the that's really the big
issue with that i would i would love to
to talk to more people and uh she's a
great addition and this uh comment
agrees
space windu 10 thank you
late to the show tonight glad you had
courtney on love your channels
thank you
whisper gaming thank you for the 4.99 a
little late to the live any theories on
who jimmy's talking to on the phone
when he says we're not friends um
oh you're talking about the the
bluetooth
teaser yeah and my thought on that was
that he was talking to jeff
maybe after after he paid him off
uh or made him or scammed him in a way
to make him think that he was paid off
and then he was trying to get him to go
away
i haven't seen any other better theories
about that
that seems the most uh that seems to be
the most um
make the most sense to me
thank you for the five dollars pmcc
tony currant thank you for the 199 i
think we're not finding out about kim
until 6 13.
oh so you think it'll be
they'll put the last piece in the puzzle
at the very end of the story that's
possible
it really depends on where she goes and
um
how that plays out it's hard to guess
beyond that when they would you know
when they would introduce more teasers
about her
pmcc i guess uh sorry if you if you did
that by accident but this one has a
question does gus have mike plant a
camera in saul's office to keep an eye
on him
as someone who's been a lawyer for the
salamancas he's useful
[Music]
i mean
maybe i i think that there's something
to the idea that
he allows mike to do as much as he does
with with
saul because
it's valuable to him to have a guy like
him around but
i i can't draw the conclusion that
you're bringing up
for sure based on anything that's coming
to mind
i do think that part will be interesting
to see a little bit more about i mean
um you know at times
courtney brought it up at times he says
hey you know i don't know who he is i
just i know a guy who knows a guy who
knows a guy and then other times he lets
on that he knows more than what he said
so that's something they could do in
that timeline to show what he really
knows about what his connection to
gus's operation is at that point
hat matter thank you for the two dollars
hhm goes to the soda guy from episode
seven
yeah okay
that's a pretty good one
um
why not
dotty x thank you for the 4.99 we need
to remember this whole plan was kim's
idea
so how does it make sense for her to
blame jimmy for dragging her in
um that might be a response to something
else i don't know i don't know if you're
referring to something that we said uh
i don't think she would i think she
would take responsibility i think she
would uh
i think she would definitely um
she's not she's
she's lucid you know i mean she lives in
reality she knows what she did and i
think she's gonna feel bad about it
the ref thank you for the two dollars
kim disappears with the red band van
vacuum guy
what is she running for though from
though you know i mean this is obviously
a popular theory that's been out there
forever but after this last episode what
is she what is she actually running from
you know it looks like they're gonna fix
fix it up you know that that uh
if they can just manage to go back to
living their life like they were before
then
you know
this will this will not come back to
haunt them i think it's
i think that's the most interesting part
at the end of this episode is that they
they
they won't be able to do that
they'll be able to know that that's what
they they're supposed to do
but you know it's it's easier said than
done
and i do think that that is the end of
the super chat and if i missed any i'm
i'm terribly sorry um
sometimes when it gets out of the gets
way out of hand um
it's a little harder to track what the
next one is
when there's a lot of chat but um
i'm gonna call it a day since i'm in
here by myself
um
i want to thank everyone who showed up
everyone that was a guest it was good to
have the conversation
there's a lot more about this episode
that i wanted to talk about so
be on the lookout for some more videos
because there was a couple of things
that i really wanted to get to in our
conversation that we got nowhere near
because of the the questions which isn't
a bad thing it's not a bad problem to
have
but but there is a lot on my mind that
i'd still like to to get to so um
maybe the maybe there'll be another live
stream
before the next episode i'm not sure how
that would work i'm doing um
for all mankind which is another show
that i love as well and that's on friday
so
my schedule is a little bit more a
little busier but uh definitely more
stuff to come we got another question
here if you have them post them now
because
i am going to shut this down in a second
so if you
if you have a last last-minute question
you have about five minutes to get it up
there because after that i'm going to be
gone
mark opie thank you for the uh canadian
five dollars kim appeared with bars in
shadows across her face she'll end up in
jail
again this is something that was a very
reasonable
theory to have
it's a little bit harder to to imagine
that at the end of this episode
for me anyways you know i like it it's
more of a feeling
but you know she can't go to jail for
for
[Music]
for howard without everybody else being
implicated at the same time in my mind
so
maybe she does something else and gets
arrested but it
ever since howard died the whole idea of
kim going to to jail theory lost some of
its uh
some of its viability for me
all right well
i'm gonna wrap it up there thanks
everyone for coming out
be on the lookout for
more content about this episode and like
i said maybe another stream uh
we'll see
they're not doing regular
teasers it doesn't seem like with a lot
of footage so
i'm trying to figure out what my second
video this week will be
and maybe i'll do another stream and
that way we can get to some of the other
people on
and get to more of these questions and a
little bit more about what we didn't get
to in this conversation so thanks for
coming out please like the video please
come back in the future and thanks for
watching i'll talk to you soon